let's go to our caller from the 3:05
area code caller from 3:05 what's on
your mind today
hey David um this is Esteban currently
in Atlanta Georgia but I reside in
Orlando alright so as you know Pelosi
has been withholding the articles of
impeachment for a couple weeks now I
think this is really genius I need to
meet you know he might say that she's
doing this because she wants you know to
guarantee you a fair trial but I think
it's really clear that she's just trying
to make us aware of a war of attrition
you know more and more devastating
information comes out on Trump more and
more scandals become public and you know
he's still serving as an impeached
president so you know Shirley just can't
look good right you know in emails just
came out hiding the fact that Trump was
the one who made the order to withhold
the aide and you know Trump is might
argue of that you know the Democrats are
scared but I think that you know it's
really clear that she's doing this maybe
to I guess sort of muddy Trump's name
you know 5:3 a poll just came out and
support for removal of office for Trump
has reached 57 percent which is the
highest it's ever been so my question is
you know what's your take on this but
more specifically how long do you think
the Democrats should continue the
strategy and do you think that all this
bad information coming out on Trump is
going to ricans ances of winning okay
good so a lot of good questions there I
I do think that in the immediate the
withholding of the articles of
impeachment from the Senate is a smart
move I said it before Donald Trump is an
impeached president is becoming
increasingly erratic you know the
problem is that he may become so erratic
that he does things that lead to the
deaths of tons of people like starting a
war with Iran because he thinks it'll
help him get reelected so that is
definitely a concern but so far the
articles of impeachment being withheld
is throat you know making Trump even
more erratic you're absolutely correct
that we are learning more and more
things in fact those emails showing that
Donald Trump was the one ordering the
Ukrainian aid be withheld those are
emails that were denied to the house
during the impeachment inquiry and
investigation which Mitch McConnell also
wanted to
from the Senate trial and how do you
justify excluding those from the Senate
trial at this point given that they have
gone public so I agree with all of that
stuff the concern I have is if you hold
impeachment until after the November of
2020 election if you withhold the
articles from the Senate until after the
2020 election I think that Trump maybe
gets himself re-elected because it
doesn't do any that the trial doesn't do
any damage to Trump at the same time
there's a risk that if you start the
impeachment trial in July in August the
Republican National Convention is in
August that Trump and Republicans are
successfully able to paint Democrats as
merely political and calculating and it
could actually inspire people to get out
there and vote for Trump because he
convinces them that he's the victim and
he's a martyr so I think in general this
has been a good decision by Nancy Pelosi
I'm not sure of the endgame and I'm not
sure at what point it might backfire
right
I remember watching I remember what News
Channel was on but this is Dinah
Madalena Richmond families like he's
correctly predicted like every election
since 1984 Oh Alan's and I yeah we've
interviewed said was that the yeah oh
really interesting so he said that
there's a there's like 13 factors that a
sort of make up or decide the chances of
a president being elected or re-elected
yes and I think something like they
consisted of like you know scandals but
one of the big ones was like in teaching
um he said that uh at least he's he
claims that the only way Trump would
lose the election is if you know the
Democrats move forward with impeachment
and it doesn't matter you know if he's
actually successfully removed from
office all that matters is um that you
know there's out there's obviously going
to be trial and I think that the more
you know the more Nancy withholds are
these articles I think the harder it is
to deny Trump you know an impeachment
trial in the Senate which I think
ultimately will just you know increase
his chances of losing the reelection you
may be right I'm not sure and I know
Allan Lichtman is well-respected and to
me it's it's less clear but we've only
got ten months left so we're going to
know pretty soon yeah all right thank
you so much for the call I appreciate it
thank you so much that is all the time I
have today apologies to everybody I was
not able to get to but we have we have
all year to take phone calls so we'll
take a quick break and be back with more
after this